hello grammarians we are once again
learning how to master time and become
time wizards which is of course what you
will be if you master all the tenses of
english but if you want to become an
additional time wizard if you want to
get i don't know a second hat
everyone knows
all wizards wear multiple simultaneous
hats if you want to wear a second hat on
top of your other time wizard hat that's
the silliest thing i've ever said
then you will have to learn the
prepositions of time now here's
something weird and cool about
prepositions of time is that once upon a
time all of these were physical
prepositions like before and after
just used to mean uh behind and in front
of you know that
they later took on this additional uh
connotation of time just over the course
of english-speaking history
people took this literal meaning of you
know before
and after
and made it representational you know
this moment occurred
in front of this one in time but behind
this other one in time it's a metaphor
we're using space to represent time
anyway i just thought that was really
cool let's talk about how all of these
work i'm just going to list a couple of
the most
most famous prepositions of time and
write an example sentence so let's go
through these after and before as we've
established these these are time
relationships that you know refer to
something happening
after so when something is completed
say the bats come out after the sun goes
down
and
before
this occurs
prior to some point in time so
it is behind an action so you can say
can you take out the garbage before you
leave the house
at is very precise
when we're talking about at we're
talking about a single moment in time
we could say the vampire wakes at 10 pm
there he is
emerging from his coffin there is the
his oh that's not the sun the sun would
burn a vampire no that's a um that's his
little clock
it's got a tail because it's like a
little wacky cat clock
no a bat clock
that doesn't have a that doesn't have a
tail it's got a little stubby tail
oh i really want a bat clock now anyway
okay uh by
uh this this is a really precise end
time but not a very precise beginning
time
so you could say something like this
place had better be clean by 3 p.m buddy
and if you say something like that
you're not especially concerned that the
place might be clean before three that
would be nice
but it's only relevant to you that the
cutoff time is at three o'clock so the
end is precise that's the connotation
there but the beginning is not
four denotes duration how long something
has been going on so you could say
i've been a chef for 40 years
i haven't but that would be cool and
difficult but you know what this is khan
academy you can cook anything
in denotes a bounded duration so it's
something that lasts for a specific
amount of time like a limited period
okay so let's just say
bounded
duration
so that covers usage like you know in
march
or
in the middle ages
both both of those things are like set
periods
march has a beginning and an end
the middle ages have a beginning
and an end
it's a bounded duration
on has a specific connotation
it's something that happens on a
specific day
you could say something like on the 4th
of july many americans watch fireworks
and eat encased meats
mind you not everybody eats hot dogs or
likes fireworks so i said many not
all synths is kind of like
bi
except it's more about the precision of
the start point rather than the end
point so precise beginning
since 1974 our company has made nothing
but toasters
until is also precise
but it's a precise
ending time
you have until midnight to rescue the
ambassador break the curse and save
prince wilbur
right so there's a precise ending there
you have until midnight and then you
can't rescue the ambassador break the
curse or save any princes
but what you can do is learn anything
these are some of the most essential
time prepositions
dave it out